[Music]
tweet from a New Jersey mothers put a
very young face on the fight over the
Senate health care bill Allyson Chandra
shared this photo of a two hundred and
thirty-one thousand dollar medical bill
for her two-year-old son Ethan it was
retweeted more than 57 thousand times
the post highlighted just how much
families with sick children rely on
medical insurance
Mireya Villarreal is here with the
Chandra family's story
Mireya good morning well good morning
Ali Chandra never thought that one
Twitter post could spark so much
interest so her goal was simple put the
health care debate into perspective by
reminding politicians in Washington
their decision affects real people
children like her son Ethan how did you
get a scar thank God does it hurt no
Ethan Chandra was born with nine
congenital heart defects and his organs
in the wrong place he had his first
heart surgery at just six days old five
surgeries two heart catheterizations
another diagnostic procedure under
anesthesia he doesn't know any other
life did you ever ask yourself how am I
gonna pay for this I didn't have to can
you bring your reporting station over
bud
the Chandra family is covered by
employer-provided private insurance but
Ethan's fight to get better gave his
mother a li Chandra perspective on the
battle over health care I'm not sitting
here telling you that the ACA is perfect
it's not when I say I'm thankful for
Obamacare I what I mean is I'm thankful
that there's a set of laws that tell the
insurance companies look this is what
you need to cover you need to cover
essential health benefits under the
Affordable Care Act insurance plans must
meet a minimum standard of coverage this
includes a set of essential health
benefits the plans that you offer need
to cover prescription medications
hospitalizations specialist visits
Senate will come to order under the
proposed senate bill some benefits could
be removed from the state's definition
of essential health benefits he's not
aligned in a budget chandra tweeted her
two year-olds last hospital bill for
open-heart surgery and a 10-day stay the
total more than two hundred and thirty
thousand dollars luckily insurance
negotiated and covered them
geordie leaving the chandra swith just
500 dollars to pay sick one at a time
after tweeting chandra was surprised to
find out how much their story resonated
with others the chandra family is
probably better off than many because at
this point today they have what seems
like a pretty good employer-sponsored
plan and the odds are the odds are their
employee will keep their plan Columbia
University health policy professor
Michael Sparrow says there are still a
lot of uncertainties with the proposed
bill there are a lot of other folks
though a lot of other folks who may be
buying health insurance on the exchanges
right now where a lot of other folks who
are on Medicaid who might be even more
nervous than the chandra family because
they truly may be in a situation where
they will be priced out of health
insurance
very quickly Ethan will take medication
for the rest of his life and will likely
need more procedures Chandra hopes
lawmakers will keep working to improve
health care and its cost for all
Americans I don't think that right now
our government is is looking out for us
and I think we need to come together and
demand that they they do better even
though she is under an employer plan
Chandra told us when her husband changed
jobs last year their premiums almost
quadrupled critics often cite high
premiums as the Obama cares flaws
Chandra says while she knows the ACA has
its problems
she doesn't think the proposed GOP
health plan is any better right now guys
I'm glad you point out these essential
health benefits because it's important
to know what's being discussed as you
say would allow the states to waivers
one an essential health benefit to his
maternity care absolutely a lot of
uncertainties out there Thank You Maria
yeah thanks